[Musique]
le propos de cette exposition c'est de
revenir en fait sur la jeunesse du
cubisme à travers l'amitié entre
Gertrude Stein et Pablo Picasso qui se
rencontrent au début du siècle à Paris
pas très loin d'ici ça des rues de
Fleurus donc à quelques pas du
Luxembourg
cette rencontre amicale qui est un
véritable coup de foudre amical va
naître un échange artistique
intellectuel qui va beaucoup contribuer
à la naissance du cubisme
et donc ce que nous examinons un peu
plus et qui est souvent mal étudié c'est
l'importance de l'écriture de garde
trudstein dans cette dans cette histoire
et comment la poésie de Stein a été tout
à fait déterminante sur certaines
avant-gardes de l'art américain à partir
des années 50-60
[Musique]